[موسيقى]
قيل انه لا يوجد طريق ملكي للهندسه اكثر
مما هو عليه كتاب العناصر الاقليدس
عالم الرياضيات اليوناني الشهير وابو
الهندسه كما يلقب اقليدس الاسكندريه
يرجح انه ولد في الاسكندريه عام 300 قبل
الميلاد وهناك مصادر تحدثت انه ولد في
العام
330 قبل الميلاد
درس الرياضيات في الاسكندريه وهناك مصادر
تحدثت انه درس في الاكاديميه الافلاطونيه
في اليونان وقام بتدريس العلوم الرياضيه
في مصر في عهد بطليموس الاول
كتاب العناصر يعد واحدا من اكثر الاعمال
تاثيرا في تاريخ الرياضيات وبقي يدرس حتى
اوائل القرن العشرين
في هذا الكتاب استخلص مبادئ الهندسه
الاقليديه من مجموعه صغيره من المسلمات
كما اورد براهين مترابطه على جميع المسائل
الرياضيه الوارده فيه
الكتاب يتحدث ايضا عن نظريه الاعداد
والاعداد الاوليه وسدت اقليدس في التحليل
وخوارزميه اقليدس لايجاد القاسم المشترك
الاكبر من رقمين
عثر على اقدم مخطوطه لكتاب العناصر باللغه
اليونانيه في منطقه البهنسا الاثريه في
مصر وهي من الجزء الثاني من الكتاب
طبع كتاب العناصر لاول مره في العام
1482 في البندقيه وهو من اول الاعمال
الرياضيه التي تمت طباعتها بعد اختراع
المطبعه
اقليدس الف ايضا اعمالا عن المنظور
والهندسه الكرويه ونظريه الارقام والدقه
والمقاطع المخروطيه
لا يمكن ايراد جميع ما يضمه كتاب العناصر
ومؤلفات واقليدس الاخرى نظرا لضخامتها ولا
يمكن ايضا تصور الهندسه والعلوم الرياضيه
من دون مؤلفات العالم اليوناني وربما كان
الكثير من العلوم الهندسيه ليس لها وجود
ان لم يكتشف كتاب العناصر
من اشهر اقوال اقليدس قوانين الطبيعه ليست
سوى الافكار الرياضيه لله
يعتقد المؤرخون ان اقليدس وفته المنيه في
العام 260 قبل الميلاد عن عمر يناهز
السبعين عاما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات